[Music]
so
it's been almost three months since
kavan and the task force of nopats had
fled the atlante coast
on board the copperfield container ship
and during this time they've been
transporting everything from food
supplies
to computers and tech equipment the very
latest pickup
65 australian refugees next stop
singapore's brownie island
it had begun around the mid-30s when the
rising sea levels had swept away a third
of the commercial ports around the world
in an attempt to resist this new threat
to their economy
singapore built a sea wall in an effort
to shield their seaport
from the massive storms that followed on
from the rising seas
brani island was established and fully
ai automated in the way of cargo
distribution
and is one of the central hubs to the
global trade system
even though rao had provided his crew
with very convincing fake ids
to help them get through the scanners
everyone was on edge
and completely silent as they approached
their destination
the singaporean port authority was
renowned for their aggressive responses
to any unwanted visitors
so if they did happen to sense anything
out of place the repercussions could be
very unfortunate for those concerned
a specialist by the name of casper
vandala explained to kevin that
singapore used to tolerate the no pets
however things started quickly going
downhill as more and more people passing
through
started throwing out the no pat sympathy
card regardless of whether or not their
intentions were true
the us who placed an incredible amount
of value and significance
on this particular trade port were also
becoming increasingly wary of losing
this location
so they began pushing all of their
anti-nopat propaganda
which in turn eventually forced
singapore to completely shut the notepad
fleets out
they managed to dock undetected and by
using his ovp recon drone
casper sweeps the area and is able to
give the all clear
rao began quickly directing the refugees
into an old shipping container
inside was a toilet bedding and enough
supplies to last 10 days
unfortunately before they were able to
get everyone safely inside
they were spotted almost immediately a
number of alarms and sirens began to
echo throughout the port
and robotic security forces called
rangers
suddenly appeared and began advancing
towards them
casper wasting no time rapidly took them
down using his rifle
escaping back onto their vessel the
copper field slowly departed from the
dock
while rao hacked into the automated
distribution system and proceeded to
drop containers wherever he could in an
attempt to block the pursuing vessels
the singaporean port authority followed
them out into the open waters
with the sound of gunfire and battle
cries coming from behind them
their foes seemed to be catching up on
them
suddenly there was a dead silence
but then this ended abruptly and an
enormous booming sound from a cannon
being fired was heard
kavan and the others braced for impact
yet almost immediately he realized that
the sound didn't come from behind them
out in front of the copper field on the
horizon they see a huge number of
fishing trawlers
container ships tug boats and much much
more
it's a no-pat fleet the singaporean port
authority is now vastly outnumbered
and immediately they call off the chase
and head back towards the coast
the copperfield has been floating around
somewhere in the yellow sea for the last
two days
waiting on orders from higher up
specialist webster mckay tells kavan
that oz generally only provides just
enough intel to keep the operations
moving
he sends this out via telegraph with
only basic points
so only those intended to receive these
messages would be able to understand
them
kevin has been passing the time by
keeping up to date following the steady
stream of news being broadcasted around
the globe
as it turns out there was one story in
particular that would soon involve the
copperfield and its crew
[Music]
the news report talks of an incident at
daesong electronics
korea is one of the few success stories
of the last decade
their economy wasn't just surviving it
was growing
and one of the companies that can be
credited with the bulk of the success
is daisong electronics
before the blackout in 2040 that dropped
earth back into the dark ages
most of the world had switched over to
satellite internet
this earthbound internet service
provider came up with a solution that
would get the world back online
without the need to roll out expensive
hardware across the planet
this isp was called k-net
by 2041 daesong had 60 of all internet
traffic
running through its servers which in
turn flowed through to the quantum data
center
in the middle of song do naturally the
sheer volume of information going
through this data center
would provide a significant tactical
advantage for those who were able to get
their hands on it
so us and russian intelligence networks
keep a very close eye on what's
happening here
at around 7 30 a.m an executive
assistant
at daesong electronics made out with 10
terabytes of internal data
from the headquarters in seongdu south
korea and escaped on a stolen corporate
helicopter
the identity behind this was an
unexpected korean woman in her twenties
immediately it was assumed that she was
a foreign intelligence asset
from one of the two main superpower
countries the us
or russia but what they didn't realize
is that there was a third faction who
was interested in this intel war
after kavan finished with the news he
headed up above deck
while looking over the horizon he
noticed something approaching in the
distance
it was a black helicopter and on the
side was the daesong logo
the entire crew has now assembled on the
side of the ship
suddenly the helicopter appears to lose
control and eventually crashes down in
the distance
caven looks around at the crew but no
one seems to be particularly concerned
about this
and a minute later it would all make
sense
above the ship there was a woman
parachuting down
it was the korean woman who had made off
with the intel from daesong
electronics after she landed
on the deck casper and rau quickly
escort her inside
she is known as specialist j sue pake a
non-pat
agent put in place by oz who's been
working undercover
at daesong
reflects back on his time over the
months with his crew of no pets
the government had led everyone to
believe that they were the enemy
but after singapore he was convinced
that they were the sympathetic underdogs
making the hard choices to help the
struggling survive
but now he was witnessing them
infiltrate international tech giants
beating the global superpowers at their
own game
perhaps there is far more to this group
of nationless soldiers that we've been
led to believe
[Music]
[Music]
you